notre invité de glace y est professeur
de droit spécialiste de sciences
politiques américaines
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur rtl france on s'en souvient de
ces festivités un minima l'année
dernière en raison de la pandémie en ans
plus tard elle les états unis ont changé
de président au delà de l'indépendance
les américains célèbrent aujourd'hui une
forme de retour à la normale un tous les
dieux
si le nom mars et sont un demi mais avec
un demi mirin de tout nom de rassembler
dominion ensemble prendre pendant le
qu'ovide donc un an maintenant des
métriques leduc l'un comme dans l'autre
on a fait des grandes réunions dans la
maison blanche les démocrates se
plaindre et maintenant il semble comme
drogba est en fait la même chose c'est
tout et et ronces et responsable dans
tous les états unis un homme violent qui
s'étendent partout et on est premiers
obligé de porter des masques aux mains
des gens qui refusent d'être vaccinés
oui si important de célébrer
l'indépendance des états unis mais pas à
la coupe des millions de vies et dans
l'esprit des américains malgré cette
pandémie toujours très présentes vous le
rappeler ce que l'heure est à la fête
au plan sanitaire on le rappelle donc à
joe biden a donc échoué à atteindre cet
objectif pour ce 4 juillet d'une
première dose administrée à 70% de la
population adulte le nombre de nouveaux
cas trop vide ne baisse plus depuis la
mi juin puis vous le rappeliez le vire
le
varian delta se propage quel est votre
regard sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire par joe biden aujourd'hui dans
la frite donald trump
oui ok on a deux éléments d'abord si on
regarde les sondages une majorité un peu
près 64% des américains approuvent de la
jasse de l'administration bayonne de
kobe mais on a aussi les deuxième chose
que son objectif de 70 % si chypre et et
il y avait une date et on a dépassé sa
date et est donc le vaincre le pain de
mie ces centrales aux stratégies de joe
boyd et donc faire un échec que ce date
c'est un problème
recevant à ce que ça veut dire que à mon
problème vacciner les populations mais
aussi parce que ça montre comme les
promesses ne sont pas tenues et et dans
un programme cinq familles qui vivent
c'est un peu avec lui de notre ans il a
perdu beaucoup de confiance en eux
livrés pas son projet et si les
démocrates ne réussit pas 70% en mois
d'août
maintenant c'est le prognostic à la si
ça continue ou moins de 70 60 en
septembre en octobre
ça ça pourrait dire que les états unis
n'ont pas une immunité du troupeau 1/2
en haîti exigé pour arrêter le pain de
mie et après ça c'est nous des vagues
avec le ghana au delà de ce bilan
sanitaire plus largement quel bilan est
ce que vous dressez après six mois de
joe biden ouais bien sûr je suis un peu
probable parce qu'un pour moi les
optiques al étrangère des etats-unis à
un échec de règles soient comme meken
résidence broc mais si on regarde les
sondages il était stable entre 52 et 60
et 56 70 cm quand dans les sondages
depuis le début soutient joe biden
pensez un peu plus que la moitié de
population tranquillité de bien mais ça
veut dire aussi que presque moitié de la
population ne sont pas contentes et
comme un regard proches ces sondages ses
partisans 90% des démocrates m ce que
byden fait et 18% entre républicaine
donc maintenant le pronostic de brighton
et bien sûr par l'opposition
républicaine comme baissé et il faut
éliminer ce perspective avec les
légistes ration bipartisans va essayer
avec le programme une fraction des
blocages et des canaris dans les
primaires pour la prochaine électorale
prochaine cycle les législatives
on va voir ses divisions augmente et
l'impossibilité d'accomplir les grands
programmes est ce que vous direz que je
donne un toutefois réussi à apaiser
certaines tensions souvient de ces
manifestations il ya un an contre le
racisme dont l'afflux d'abord de la fois
vainqueur de levante femme est 2020 oui
je pense que comme dans le rôle
symbolique de président des états unis
il a épuisé les esprits d'abord avec les
nominations de camarès comme son vice
présidente et les nominations de
nouvelle ministre de défense noire
indienne américaines comme son ministère
de l'intérieur donc il a fait beaucoup
de symbolisme mais les choses
probablement qu'ils aient joué en
ferrain de l'épier semant le social sur
la question raciale
c'est l inculpation de le policier qui a
tué just wait sassetti très important
même si l'on sacrificielle individus
pour créer des pays les fêtes c'est
quand y'en a plus des grandes
manifestations
blacklight semaine et ça donne un moment
pour réflexion et pour les foins
mais doubaï tine a trip à faire dans le
racisme dans les polices parce que plus
que 80
dix poids santé police aux états unis
sont sous le contrôle des états et pas
sur le confort du gouvernement fédéral
qui explique qu'il a échoué jusque là à
mettre en place des réformes à la fois
sur la police ou encore l'immigration
oui ce sont deux fois moi je croyais pas
qu'il a jamais réussi avec l'immigration
parce qu'il a des priorités et il a
dépensé son capital politique sur le
plan des imf stocks ce qui va avoir une
ifec économiques importantes
donc je ne crois pas qu nalgon réformer
l'immigration qui était promis pour la
réforme de la prise c'est au le contrôle
des deux wild eyes de washington il a
proposé par son ministère sont anthony
john rossant ministère de justice
un certain nombre de réformes qui
pourrait aider un peu dans la
criminalité mais le fond' il faut faire
au niveau des états il s'assied au le
contrôle de président le système faudra
donc no ippo l'immigration ni pour la
réforme de police pas de n'a pas réussi
il a mis son capital politique
si le programme festif 1,2 triangle d'or
messi veut beaucoup pour qu'ils se
regardent le ciel je rappelle que est
professeur de droit et spécialiste de
sciences politiques américaines